welcome
to this virtual extraordinary meeting of
the council
before we commence i would like to ask
everyone
to join with me in a two-minute silence
as we pay tribute and remember those who
have lost their lives in conflict
while fighting for our freedom thank you
may i first remind all of you of some
domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking that you do
not interrupt
other speakers members are reminded
not to use the messaging chat function
during the meeting
unless it is report a pecuniary
non-pecuniary interest or
to notify the chair that you wish to
make a proposal
that if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
additionally you'll be invited to speak
and ask questions by the chair
please await your turn if members lose
connection to the meetings
they must contact the member support
officer mandy smith
as soon as possible as this is a virtual
meeting
you will not need to stand to address
the chair
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except when there are confidential
or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you're also
consenting to being filmed by the
council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
i will now move to the agenda
item one apologies for absence
jan
thank you chair i have received
apologies for absence from councillor
sean dawson councillor holt councillor
granger howard and councillor mayberry
i have um all councillors have marked
themselves as president
apart from that in the council meeting
apart from councillors huron
and councillors lindsay are our cancers
huron and lindsay present please
uh yes i'm present apologize if i am
thank you councillor horan are you here
no okay i will mark that down then thank
you chair
thank you so i don't think we need a
roll call is that correct
thank you um i also just wanted to say
that i understand councillor dawson
is currently not well on behalf of the
council
i would like to wish her a full recovery
item 2 declaration of interest by
councillors
under section 31 of the localism act
2011 all members have been granted
dispensation
by the monitoring officer for all
matters relating to the local plan
therefore councillors do not need to
declare any interest
under this item are there any other
declarations of interest
thank you item three
bc 28 baber and mid suffolk
draft joint legal plan and statement of
community
involvement addendum i would like to
welcome
tom barker assistant director for
sustainable communities
and robert hobbs corporate manager for
strategic planning to the meeting
i would like to invite councillor arthy
to introduce
paper bc 28 and to move the
recommendations in the report
councillor arthi
thank you chairman yes this
is our new draft joint local plan
it is supported by more evidence than we
have ever had to support a local plan
and it has involved our staff in a
massive amount of work
in recent months it has presented huge
challenges
to meet the timetable we set in our
local development scheme
approved in july paper
bc28 refers
and i will address some key points
you will see it paragraph 1.1 and the
recommendations at 3.1 and 3.2
that i'm asking you to approve the
regulation 19
pre-submission document and to submit it
to the secretary of state for an
independent examination
a six-week period on the legal
compliance and soundness of the plan
is proposed to run from the 12th of
november to the 24th of december
at paragraph 1.3 paragraphs
4.1 to 4.3 and
paragraphs 9.1 and 9.2
you will see the background stages in
the plan's production
starting with the decision in 2016
to prepare a joint plan for baba and
mid-suffolk
in 2017 we produced our first
joint local plan consultation document
seeking views on a range of options and
that received some 14
000 responses they informed our
preferred
options consultation in 2019
with over 4 000 responses to consider
before preparing the joint local plan
you have before you today
at the same time the extensive evidence
base
sorry oh
you won't guess what's happened my
screen has just gone blank
um i'm so sorry
we'll try again
can you just wait i'm just waiting for
my screen to come back up
okay
i think i've got uh around about the
point of the extensive evidence base
have they
yes yeah okay so i'll start again
um they informed our preferred options
consultation in 2019 with over 4 000
responses to consider before preparing
the joint local plan you have before you
today
at the same time the extensive evidence
base referred to at paragraph 4.4
was being prepared these documents are
included in the appendices detailed at
paragraph
12 and in the core document library of
paragraph 13.
section 2 of bc 28 deals with the
options
which are basically that you approve
submission of the plan
or you don't if you choose not to submit
this plan
but seek instead to reinterpret the
evidence that supports it
and make changes it may well have
implications as a result of the
government's proposed changes
to the current planning system you will
remember our debate in september
and the effect the changes could have on
our calculated housing need
you will also remember that the
transitional arrangements
proposed for authorities at the stage we
are at
in plan making it is important to
recognize we have a window of
opportunity
to submit our plan based on
the existing calculation of need
if we miss this window we may well have
to plan for significantly more homes
that would require a major revision of
the plan within
with a new call for sites new
assessments
and a likely delay measured in years not
weeks or months
the plan follows the same basic format
as before
with three main sections
excuse me part one contains the
strategic policies
part two the development management
policies and part
three places and site allocations
i'm sure you will all have studied the
plan to see how it provides for our
district
our market towns and our villages and
rural settlements and i'm sure you will
have had particular regard to how it
will affect your ward
the plan includes maps showing sites
allocated for housing and employment
and all identified settlement boundaries
the strategic and development management
policies provide the principles
to guide the determination of planning
applications
they seek to balance our rural sorry
balance our growth
requirements with the need to protect
our wonderful rural landscape and rich
heritage
they recognize the importance of
affordable housing employment
town centres tourism infrastructure
the environment and climate change the
plan provides for 416 dwellings per
year or 7 900 dwellings by 2037.
around 4 000 of these dwellings already
have permission
so the plan is allocating sites to meet
the remaining need
the approach to distributing these
dwellings has sought to balance growth
in line with the outcomes from our 2017
and 2019 consultations
we need to maintain a land supply
throughout the period of the plan
so we have included a 20 buffer as a
safeguard
in case some of the proposed sites don't
come forward
a key element of the evidence
underpinning the plan is the
infrastructure delivery plan
which you will have seen labeled as e808
in the core document library
the idp provides greater detail on
infrastructure requirements
than has ever been provided before
including education
health transport emergency services
utilities digital connectivity waste
and community facilities and green
infrastructure
it identifies the need and sets out the
funding sources
including the community infrastructure
levy and the time scales for delivery
we can have much greater confidence that
appropriate infrastructure will support
development
than we have ever had before
i know there are many of you that will
be particularly pleased to see the
detail in some of the local policies
including lp06 and lp07 addressing
supported and special needs housing
lp-17 through to lp-21
seeking to protect the environment
biodiversity
landscape and heritage lp
25 addressing sustainable construction
and design
these together with our strategic
policies should
guide our decisions toward better
developments in our district
the plan is a step forward in providing
for the existing
and future needs of our residents and
communities
paragraphs 410 to 414
explain the amendments required to the
statement of community involvement
which i'm also proposing today at
recommendation 3.3
given the ongoing situation with covid
we are having to make changes to the way
we would usually make these documents
available to our communities
we won't be making hard copies of the
plan available in our customer service
points
but it will be online together with all
the supporting documentation
you have with your papers today
we can't hold drop-in sessions either
but we can do virtual events
and the team will be available to
respond to all inquiries
by telephone and email
at paragraphs 9.3 to 9.8
you will see the next stages if you
approve the recommendations i am
proposing today
they include briefings for town and
parish councils
and neighborhood plan groups and the
representations being invited
do not form a consultation but they will
be subsequently made available
with the changes to sorry they will oh
dear
it's not a consultation where we will
subsequently make changes to our plan
but the representations in invited
will be made in writing and if duly made
will simply be sent to the planning
inspector for consideration
in the examination next year
chairman i want to finish by thanking
some of the people involved
firstly the staff involved i want to
thank our chief executive arthur
chalvonia
for his commitment to maintaining the
resources necessary
and additional resources when required
to enable us to deliver this plan to you
on time i also have to thank those most
directly involved
our assistant director for sustainable
communities tom barker
and his various teams with a special
mention for the strategic planning team
who have done so much of the detailed
work and fulfill is bell
for the extra the extra help his plan
has provided when we needed it my
biggest thank you is reserved for rob
hobbs
our corporate manager for strategic
planning who is with us tonight to
answer any detailed questions you may
have
rob has been absolutely committed to
producing for us and evidenced an
evidence-based plan of the highest
quality and has carefully and
methodically put together the document
you have before you today
it is a real achievement for robin his
team and i thank you
rob finally some of the members involved
i want to thank our council leader john
ward
for entrusting me with the task and for
supporting me throughout
i also want to thank david byrne the
cabinet member for planning at mid
suffolk
for his commitment and shared ambition
to produce a plan for both councils
we have worked together with the joint
local plan member working group
to assess and review the developing plan
in accordance with the evidence base
and taking into account the
representations received following last
year's consultation
so i must also thank councillors beer
busby and jameson
from baber and councillors guthrie field
and stringer
from mid-suffolk sometimes it took a
while to arrive at a position we could
accept
but i don't feel alone in presenting
this plan to you
i am doing it on behalf of the member
working group
chairman i am i am proposing the three
recommendations
in paper bc 28 at paragraph
three that is approval of the jlp
pre-submission document authority to
submit to the secretary of state for an
examination
and approval of the statement of
community involvement
chairman and members thank you for your
time
thank you councillor arthy for that very
detailed proposal
um that was very helpful thank you
can i have a second dad please yes
chairman i'd like to second this
council award thank you council award
fine um we'll now move to questions and
debate
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish
however they must be relevant to the
subject under discussion
and must be a question when we get to
the debate element
counselors will only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes
and this will be timed would anyone like
to start the debate
is that john hinton
john can i would like to start open the
debate please john thank you madam
chairman yes i got some questions first
of all on um
on these the proposals in front of us um
and i'm sure that mr hobbs can uh can
answer them quite succinctly
but where we've got the page 22 where we
have the duty to cooperate
uh it says suffolk county council will
engage
well where is suffolk county council's
plan this is bd
weber district council's plan to create
houses where is the parallel suffolk
county council plan to create the
infrastructure and transport links
necessary to facilitate those houses
that's my first question i'd like to
reserve the rest
until he's had an answer to that
councillor rc
uh did you want to answer that or would
you prefer to refer it on
um i'm just looking at my papers here
um so if i can if rob's with us
um if he's ready to start answering that
um and i'll just refer back to the the
papers
rob are you available to answer that
yes um chair councillor alfie
um so effectively suffolk county
councils are a key partner of ours in
putting the plan together
um we have an infrastructure delivery
plan which is very extensive that
council life is referred to
um which counts each other county
councils are very involved in and that's
linked with um
strategic policies set out in the plan
in policy sp08
and also in some of the local policies
and also a number of the sites have site
specific infrastructure requirements as
well
and the infrastructure delivery plan
provides more detail southern county
council have their own
plans be it local transport plan or
other um various documents to help guide
um development
so just wanted to issue a council of
hinton that we work extensively with
county suffolk county council
in putting the appropriate evidence
together that underpins this plan
thank you thank you does that answer
your question
well it gives an answer i'm not sure but
it actually answers the question
um but um just to move on from there
then if that is the case and
suffolk county council are involved in
this and presumably the other consultees
like highways england are involved as
well
uh and councillor ward will will know
what i'm going to say next
um how come whereas back in 2008
highways england said that any
development of over 50 houses that
accessed out onto the a4
onto the a12 would require be required
to contribute towards junction
improvements
do we now have sort of 220 odd houses
being built in my village or proposed to
be built in my village
and not a squeak from highways england
uh
and we're now of course 12 years further
on with further
pressure on the infrastructure that's
the next point in in terms of
the infrastructure uh council henson can
i just ask you just to clarify
that part of your question um about um
50 houses or more being built and
accessing on to the
a12 i think you said did you
yes that was uh that was stated at a
public meeting that was held in
stratfordson mary
when the the uh they were talking about
proposals to close off the high-end
crossover
and also the route-based strategy was
being put forward
okay and who said that
highways england or highways agency as
they were in those days
okay great i'm not aware of that rob do
you
do you know anything about that
statement
and not particularly about the statement
but we do engage with highways england
as well as a statutory council
t uh we we have been working closely
with them
and suffolk county council in preparing
this plan and we will be publishing a
statement of common ground
um alongside the plan if it is approved
at council
um tonight and the suffolk tomorrow um
in terms of
um other matters um council hinted
refers to um
development in in um in in east berger
in particular
and um a number of days um that those
same sites already have planning
permission
and highways england and our statutory
consulting on any planning application
of a significant scale as well
yes i think probably my my what i'm
trying to sort of get to the bottom of
and trying to get some sort of
consistency
if this is going to be a workable plan
uh and that is
if the highways england are saying or
highways agency at one point are saying
50 homes you've got to improve the
junctions
and they're now saying 140 homes you
don't have to do the injunction
do the junctions they're getting just as
inconsistent as
county highways who say we will make
gateways at the entrances to villages to
slow down the traffic going through them
and then turn around and say well if we
create an open aspect that will slow
down the traffic so
it's trying to get some sort of
consistency to
these statutory consultes responses
which we can't go against when we're
talking about planning applications
but to move on from that to the moment
because i don't suppose you can
answer in any detail for those two
agencies
um but on page 262 where we're talking
about the two
developments within eastberghold
all of a sudden within the the policy
concerning those sites
and moore's lane which is la-06260
has already been granted permission and
la-061 has got outline permission
it suddenly says as it does on quite a
few of the allocated sites across the
district
i've checked on some of them not all but
some of them
it says and i quote developers should
test the potential resources on the site
to identify if poor if prior extraction
or use of the minerals on the site is
appropriate
well if that means sort of sand and
gravel does that mean that it is part of
the suffolk county council's mineral
extraction plan or does it mean that
they can dig a bloody great big hole
excuse my french and fill it up with
rubbish before putting the houses back
on it
you know it does rather sort of leave
things wide open to
uh interpretation by uh people who won't
necessarily have the interests of the
community at heart
okay councilman i don't think it means
either of those things but
um rob can you um just explain why those
why those paragraphs are in there
yeah as i alluded to earlier suffolk
county council
worked closely with us on producing the
plan and one of the areas they cover
obviously
minerals and so um that um
sentence has effectively come from a
comment made by them
um to to um effectively see
um if if prior extraction will use a
mineral on site
is appropriate so that's where that
would have come from
but how does that equate with develop
then developing the site with houses if
you've then got a dirty great big hole
to start off with
um are you expecting an answer to that
council hinton
uh well he was phrased as a as an answer
how does that equate with developing the
site if there's a dirty great big hole
to start off with
it seems like rather that we put
something in as a catch-all
uh to try and assuage somebody's uh
concerns over mineral extraction but all
we're really doing is creating a
thug uh of misinformation for people to
use
um okay but i mean let's be clear that
these are housing allocations they're
not sites for mineral extraction
then why does it talk about using the
minerals
well um if you look at the top of both
of those allocations it talks about the
provision of housing
yes but it then talks about mineral
extraction which are we
are supposed to say that those are the
those are the
uh paragraphs are in the in the correct
order and you've got to comply with
paragraph one before you can move on to
paragraph two and down the list
i don't think it means that
no it doesn't say that um
rob i'm going to come back to you if i
can i mean i don't know if there's very
much else that you can say
um but you've heard um what
council hinton's follow-up questions are
have you got any other
any other comment to make on it
can i just say that um one comment is
gonna make is you quantify the minerals
that are on site and then
try and reuse them if you can on the
site as part of the building materials
but um yeah that's that's all i'm gonna
say at this point
okay i'd like to move on now if i may
uh to the next question counselor jan
osborne
have you got a question please
yes thank you madam chairman um can i
just say first of all very much
appreciate the hard work and
the commitment from both members and
officers
to get the local plan to this stage and
i shall be supporting the
recommendations
um the old prologue site and the 4.4
acres at the back of the health center
in churchfield road sudbury
is not allocated as employment site in
the new plan
however i have been assured that a
review of employment land in baber
including sudbury
will be done following on from the
approval to this plan
my question is policy sp05
identifies churchfield road sudbury as
protected
employment land does this include the
old prologue site and the land at the
back of the health center
so could this be clarified for me please
either
rob or or councillor arthur thank you
um i'll try and answer it for you while
rob is
thinking about his answer no it doesn't
the the site there has been
subject to the same
scrutiny assessment as all other
potential employment sites it's a
need-based
assessment and i think
councillor osborne was aware of the fact
because it was in our preferred options
that this site could potentially be
removed from the employment allocations
she's obviously aware of the fact that
there's a current planning application
for the site as well
for housing the site is
not allocated for either employment or
housing
in in the current plan obviously
people can make representations um that
will be forwarded on to the inspector if
they wanted to be considered at the
examination
next year and i suggest that if if she
um believes this this site should be
included as an employment allocation
that's that's the route she ought to
take
rob can you add can i come here yes
sorry can i come in on a second one on
that so
on the policy sp05 council after where
it's got
um sudbury churchfield road that
excludes the prologue site does it and
the
land at the back of the health center um
yeah i mean i don't know about excluding
it it doesn't
include it okay thank you
rob is there anything you wanted to add
to that
not really counselor after i'd just say
that there are also policies maps in the
play section the plan if anyone's got
any um
uh consents or um wants clarification on
where lines
go around sites okay
thank you uh councillor melanie barrett
please have you got a question
yes um thank you uh later chairman
um good evening everyone um i'd like to
raise a point of interest
on page 29 of the plan there is a table
um showing housing mix and tenure i'm
showing the percentage of houses
dwellings
um uh split by one two three and four
or more beds um as a member of the
planning committee
i'm interested um it can sometimes feel
that uh if we are being asked to approve
four bedded properties
it's something to be resisted it's um
it's not needed
um and that all development should
should be
much more geared one two and three beds
um
so um in fact there seems to be a
significant need for
for four bed um especially in social and
affordable
um as as in all the ten years um and
counselor arthy has just spoken about um
the evidence gathering of this
um this exercise in this plan um
so my my question is therefore um can we
expect to see more support of the
developments
containing a mix um more forebeded
uh in the future and um
uh you know that i'd be interested uh
how how this um will pan out in the
future
um because this this document as it
suggested seeks to influence future
development
um okay um i've heard the question but
i'm not quite sure
um what sort of answer you're expecting
councillor barra
i mean support
well um i'm looking at the
the table that you're referring to here
um
and um i presume you're talking about
the top post 29
um and you're talking the shared
ownership
um 10 social rent and affordable rent
26.4 um discount home ownership and
start
well that that is the evidence
um we can't control the applications
that
come forward um and the decision
on those um will be taken either by
the planning officers assessing the
application or by you and your
colleagues
at development committee so i i don't
know
um i don't know if i can answer anything
more on that
part of the question i think is probably
around the evidence base that supports
those figures
so rob i don't know if you can help with
that can you
yes the um table you're referring to
comes from our strategic housing market
assessment and that's focusing on the
affordable
need um in terms of the market housing
that's often
um well that's put forward by the
applicant themselves
as part of a mix and we have policies in
the plan to try and ensure
that overall we have a good mix of
housing across all ten years and types
in the development so we wouldn't single
out particular so four bed house
as um what we'd be seeking to achieve
but we would expect to mix
but say this table is referring um to
the affordable element of that
so council barrack were you surprised
that the evidence showed
um 26 for um affordable
housing social rent and affordable rent
is that is
were you surprised by that yeah yeah it
certainly caught my eye
um to to examine that needs you know
obviously i i looked again at the all
the ten years across that
table um but yeah thank you for that
um i just wanted to say also i support
this plan
um i believe it's
you know in particular in the areas of
the aonb
and heritage or historic that
um particularly affect my ward um
i've tried to examine it thoroughly on
those grounds and
and i think it's written positively with
what we want to see
rather than you know what we don't want
to see so
i do support it thank you
thank you councillor barrett uh
councillor davis have you got a question
please
i do thank you very much um first of all
i want to
commend um the work that's gone into
this i
i attended a couple of meetings right at
the beginning of interest
it's incredible amount of work and um
and as you say clive a lot of two in a
throne and um
disagreement but finally agreement my
question actually comes from a developer
i was speaking to today
who who is also as all developers will
be very keen
to see um the jlp come forward
and his question is basically how robust
is it
given how the government constantly
changes
the goal posts in terms of development
in what they demand and what they expect
from
from all um planning authorities
how do you robust you see this clive
um well it's it's a new plan
um it's fully compliant it's
up to date um as i said earlier it's the
the most evidence that's ever supported
one of our plans
so if the question is how robust do i
think it is
obviously it's got to go through
examination
and on to adoption but i've been on the
council for
what nearly 30 years now and
um and seen a few local plans go through
council
and i have to say that this is the most
evidence-based
it is the the best plan that we've ever
had
um it provides for our future better
than any plan has ever done before
um so i think it's it's the very
best that we can have moving forward
in that regard um i think it will be
very robust the only caveat to that of
course is that the government does keep
changing um the the parameters that
we're working under
so we will have to wait and see what
happens with regard to the changes to
the the current planning system
which i referred to earlier on we'll
have to wait and see what happens with
the white paper
and with regard to some of the
by biodiversity and environmental issues
there's the environment bill next year
as well so
what government does will have a
huge impact on us um and of course
the i guess the minute you adopt your
plan
um things have changed and you have to
work on the next one or work on changes
but for this moment in time i i have to
say it is
i i believe the very best plan um
that that we can submit
yeah thank you for that clive i totally
agree with you and i think
that will give a lot of developers um
and residents
you know because obviously they have the
most important things on there
um a great deal
of comfort
thank you thank you thank you councillor
davis
councillor hardaker have you got a
question please
i have a question from a bunch of
residents who don't feel particularly
comforted by this
i represent ipswich fringe um where
we're getting
um quite a large percentage of these
houses allocations
um but i don't want to go on about that
now i have a specific question about
specific allocation
and that is um la 116 by sprawling on
page 57 of the plan
was not there in the draft plan it has
recently
in recent years had two applications for
50 houses
declined by committee on
it's the basis of the environment
traffic but specifically
listed buildings and since those
applications have been declined it has
appeared in the plan as a site that is
currently suitable for development so
i'm curious
how this has happened why as a site that
where
we're telling developers is not suitable
has the plan decided is suitable
okay you're talking about
one specific site um
and um the
the obvious answer to you is that if you
don't agree with its inclusion
um you should make your representations
which will be forwarded on to the
inspector
and will be given due regard
i'm not sure how much i ought to say
about
a particular site um
but it's it's fair to say
that um we have looked at ways to
address um the the apparent
tension between uh developing jlp
and the committee decisions that you
referred to of refusal
and i guess that gave us two
alternatives one was to
concede on the appeal or the other was
to concede
on the plan and and remove the
allocation
but the the third way is
is what i think we should be doing
because it's more pure and logical
and that is that we shouldn't be doing
either of those
the joint local plan addresses an area
of land
but the application was a detailed
proposal
so the way that i see things developing
with regard to the site that you
refer to is that there is
an appeal um ongoing
if if that is dismissed
we can look at the reasons um that the
inspector gives
and we can ask the jlp inspector
to um adjust or remove the allocation
in line with the views expressed by the
appeal inspector
if the appeal is allowed the jlp
inspector will have to accept
that the site has permission um so
just going back to the question of of
whether we should
concede on the appeal or concede on the
jlp allocation
i think we obviously have to respect the
decision of committee
but they they don't write the jlp
piecemeal this is a document that's been
prepared
um over a number of years
um and as i said earlier is very
firmly based on a lengthy
evidence-gathering period
the committee can only determine the
application they have before them
and um they
they did that um but i think that as far
as the jlp is concerned we we have to
also
respect the the evidence that supports
that
so what i'm trying to say to you is um
i i get that you're trying to say that
there
appears to be almost hypocrisy here that
on the one hand
committee are saying um an application
for housing on that site should not be
allowed
and on the other hand it still appears
in our joint local plan submission
document
as a site that may be suitable um for
housing
but i hope you will accept that those
those apparent tensions
will resolve themselves
does that i don't know if it answers
your question but does that give you my
view on the on the issues you're trying
to highlight
uh yes thank you seems to be that
um yeah i don't know what i want to say
thank you thank you
um counselor lindsay have you got a
question please
yes thank you um sorry i need to apply
my
background um yeah
uh just to
the background to my question is of
course about an allocation in my
village builderston um 75 houses on
watch
south land south of watching road um
the there were a number of sites put
forward around billston
um in the call for sites some time ago
um all of them by this were dismissed
and all i could find out about the
reasons
was a sort of very short sentences
produced by who i don't know in
it's somewhere in the buried in the
document and
i looked them up and you know just
seeing
less than a sentence like a note isn't
very convincing
and and the parish council and i were at
the view that
the worst possible site was the one
that's been allocated
and there were others that had better
cause to
to to be allocated we accept that we
have to have
some you know buildston's sort of
labeled as sustainable because it has
one shot so we therefore
accept it you know you have to have some
development but um
uh there seemed to be no opportunity
for a genuine consultation with
residents about
which sites were chosen to be allocated
um
what opportunity is there or was there
for for that for that to have to have a
proper discussion
about you know what what the village
what the residents thought
was the best site thank you um
okay um the the history
um goes back through the 2017
consultation the 2019 preferred options
um you um had an opportunity yourself
to feed into that the
the sites that made it to
this draft's mission document
went through the member group we spent
um several sessions um
looking at the appropriateness of the
the various submitted sites as far as
the the evidence
supporting this site over any other
is concerned i don't have that to hand
and i'd be very surprised
if um rob hobbs had it to hand but i
will ask him in a minute
um the the thrust of your question
though is similar to others
and that is that there's something in
the plan
um that you might not agree with and the
answer to that concern is the same as
before
which is that this you know you have
this opportunity
to make your representations and they
will be forwarded on to the inspector
and considered
in the examination but i don't know if
rob
if you've been able to access any of the
background for the
for the builders and sites have you
if i could just say that um you know
when sites are submitted to us
um we we also have a strategic housing
and economic land availability
assessment which does an initial
appraisal
of sites but they're also underpinned by
various evidence-based studies
um detail in our core document library
which is appended to the council report
and they've all gone through um
sustainability appraisal as well
those sites that are deemed suitable for
development so
um yes i just point council
lindsay to the underlying evidence base
in this regard
so i think the answer is councillor
lindsay you might not point to it as a
suitable site for development but the
evidence base does
well i've seen the i mean it
okay i won't i won't prolong this too
long but just to say
hey i did make my objection to this as
soon as i was
collected as a baby counselor in 2019
um b and the parish council did so
earlier
um but um and b
all i've seen is the i've seen the um
the appraisal of the site that was
allocated and it's basically got two
you know it's got two red marks and two
positive rocks and they say on balance
the positive is better than
the negative but um anyway that i don't
find that
very convincing but i will raise that
uh down the line yeah thank you thank
you
councillor newman
thank you thank you madam chairman um
this is a question for
clive or rob land east of carson's drive
great corner
um can you confirm that it's not in the
plan
um sorry councillor newman are you
looking at a particular i mean
you said you said can you confirm that
land isn't in the plan i mean
are you looking at a particular plan and
there's a
a site and you want to know
it was it's it's soft prospect here
within great corner
and um there was mention of a developer
wanting to put it in the plan and
obviously the parish council
and great corner don't want it in the
plan and the residents don't want it in
the plan i was just wondering if you've
you've noted it anywhere well have you
had a look and have you seen it
uh well i it has been mentioned by that
if i could just help yes cancel a beer
here i think he's referring to the land
safe of davidson close great corner the
sheila
site that was put in that um
i believe wasn't supported by um
um buyers by baber um
i think newman's just wants that to be
clarified that that is still the case
well can we just would you mind coming
through the chair
please apologies madam chairman
yes i just thought i was helping out you
were thank you
okay could i just refer councillor
newman to page 278 if he's got the
document in front of him
i can't unfortunately i can't get the
document up at the moment i was having
trouble
so i haven't got a document at the
moment but
have you got it there have you
um yes i've got it here but i
i don't know if anybody else knows the
land that you're referring to
obviously if you want confirmation that
it's not in we need to know
exactly what you're referring to does
does rob no rob are you are you aware of
the land that councillor newman is
talking about
yes i was just raising my hand to come
in um yes i it's in the strategic
housing and economic
land availability assessments
potentially suitable for development
but that's only an evidence-based
document that doesn't allocate sites so
then sites
need to be then taken forward for
allocation and then it's not in the
joint local plan as an allocation
so i can confirm that that's a question
oh
that's what i wanted to hear so i will
be supporting the plan
knowing that that's not internet thank
you thank you clive
okay thank you councillor newman
um councillor alison mccraw please
councilman crawl have your question
i've just the microphone surface pro
issue
uh it shut itself off i have a specific
question and i appreciate we're all
going to be doing a little bit of this
because we're all looking out for our
own patches as opposed to the broader
aspect of a local plan on page 228
i think this addresses a difference
about how the uh allocations are decided
um and strategic housing assessments uh
are reached
page two to eight deals as an allocation
in brantham
which uh previous strategic housing
assessments whether they were schleizel
schmarz
apologies have assessed at first 50
and most recently in the uh
last version of the
consultation for 30
a subsequent planning application has
arrived
for 128 properties
on this piece of land this piece of land
that we previously assessed at 30
and our allocation now assesses this
site
as being um worthy of approximately 125
dwellings
quite a few people have wondered how you
can move from 50 to 30 well those two at
least are in the same
mark you know same ballpark suddenly to
125
approximately which purely
coincidentally
matches up with 128 for an existing
application um are our judgments
on a site guided by applications
when they exist or are we actually
making a rational
independent assessment i'd like to have
an answer to those questions
okay um well the only time that you will
find
a number put in our plan
that's um affected by or or dictated
by an application is is where consent
already exists
so as you know there are quite a few
sites
in the plan which have already got the
benefit of planning permission
um and there we have probably got a a
good indication of the numbers
um with regard to the brantham site i'm
afraid i
don't know whether there are any
outstanding planning permissions on the
site
there are not i'm saying i'm telling you
quite frankly there are not
okay great this is an existing
application subsequent to
the last consultation which which
identified this site
suitable for northern perimeter
development of up to 30 dwellings
yet the allocation has has been raised
to approximately 125 which it seems
very close to the number of 128 of this
actual application
okay i think i'm getting close so i
haven't got the preferred option
document in front of me but are you
saying that in the preferred options
document this site was identified
but was identified for 30 and now
in the submission draft it's identified
for 125.
approximately yes that's exactly what
i'm saying in the um
in the uh um section 18 document the
last consultation held last year
yes okay great and the application was
subsequent to that
okay i'm sure that rob will be able to
answer that question
yes thank you um well as part of putting
the plan together we have to ensure that
it's some
effective it's one of the tests of
soundness that it's deliverable
so each stage of the um uh the plan
making process
where we obviously receive
representations through the various
stages of consultation which would
include developers putting forward sites
and their delivery assumptions but we
also have engagement with developers in
terms of what delivery they expect on
the site
um and also when we know that
information
we undertake further further we've
undertaken further evidence-based work
um since the previous round of
consultation which is all published on
our
our um on our website so um
in answer to your question it's a bit
both i suppose in terms of
you know delivery information put
forward by by a site promoter
doesn't mean that we necessarily take it
all as as read
but we we certainly um then and every
site goes through
um evidence-based work to ensure that
that proposed figure
can be delivered or not and if it's
appropriate and in this case um
as council macro um at least two the
previous plan had a
different site area um that was proposed
for allocation
now further evidence base to say work
has been undertaken and
what's being proposed now is a larger
site boundary which then equates to
approximately 125 weddings
as being able to be developed delivered
on this site
the uh i might just take follow on on
that
chair um the original
allocation a much shorter one
uh was an assessment we made
only last year and it just seems
purely coincidental that the plan isn't
being driven
by an actual application rather than our
strategic housing assessment
i i find that a disturbing uh piece of
work and i believe that the
the parish of branson um and the people
of branson will be probably will be
making a submission to the inspector
that this is um the wrong way round uh
we make the uh
local plan not the developers
okay thanks for that um i am aware that
we are talking um about quite a few
parochial issues if you like um
this is not really the time for every
member to open a debate on on the merits
of um sites in their ward
so i i mean i just say that because
this this is our draft submission
document there's been a tremendous
amount of preparation go into it
um and i think that if individual
members on behalf of
parishes or communities or those
parishes themselves
um want to make individual
representations
the best way to do that is
as i said earlier to make those
representations in the six week period
and they will be forwarded on to the
inspector
otherwise we could end up with a debate
this evening that goes through
all of the villages and everybody's ward
and that could take a long time
thank you chair may i just respond to
that point
yes and then i only have one more
question to follow anyway
my point was meant to be less specific
to an individual's site
but more to the driving of the strategic
housing assessment
okay um
councillor jameson is your question very
site specific or
are you planning to talk a more general
question about the
document it is site-specific but
hopefully it will just be a quick
site specific it's not um
if i can just get that in okay
okay thank you madame chair um i'm just
looking at page 328 this shows
um an lso one allocate
lindsey thai looking at the policy for
lso one there's no mention of that
within the policy i just wondered if
that's an oversight or
um no you you will find quite a lot of
these
in the plan um obviously you're familiar
with the ones in your ward
but there are quite a lot of lso1 sites
they were previously identified
as extensions to the built up area
boundary so
in the preferred options you would have
seen
either a new settlement boundary defined
which is what happened
in in a lot of villages lindsay one of
them had two defined
um and when those settlement boundaries
were defined
um there was um
due regard given um two um sort of
potential sites within a cluster of
development so this has occurred
throughout the plan you will see a lot
of ls if you look at other villages you
will see quite a lot of lso1
sites so they're ones that some of them
have already got planning permission
um and were included in the redrawn
um settlement boundaries for villagers
um
and have now been labeled as lso1 sites
some of them are quite small if you have
a look at the
list you'll see i think the largest
is 51 in
cockfield and that's actually one that's
already got consent
so the um the settlement boundary was
drawn around it
and i think that's the largest of the
lso one sites but there
are a lot um and there is a schedule of
them
at um i might need i might need rob's
help here
um there's a schedule at
can chairman can i just ask rob for the
page there's a there's a schedule
yes please do okay thank you thank you
it's 209.
209 is it yeah so if um councillor
jameson
um looks at the schedule on 209 page 209
he will see um all of the lso1 sites
that's that's what i'm saying there uh
counselor arthur uh lindsay's not within
that
uh policy there so i wondered
is that an extensive list of all the
lso1 sites or
gosh you've picked something here um
i'm going to defer to rob i think it
should be in there but it's not i think
is the answer
because it's an lso one site um
and it's not in that list that was my
question yeah
rob can you help on this
yeah i'll um i'll have to have a look at
that so um
we're saying that it's allocated as lsa1
on the policies map and it's not shown
in the schedule
yes that's right
okay
yeah i mean the policies map is is the
key um map um showing the allocation so
um
as long as it's on that map then that
that's okay for the plan to proceed
oh yeah i wouldn't question it it's just
that um
in the policy schedule it details the
number of dwellings
so without uh lindsay in there
it's a bit you wouldn't know how many
dwellings that
allocation refers to tom barker i see
you've got your hand up
are you wanting to um help on this
please
if that's okay yes please come in
if i could come in here yes please do
yes councillor jameson this this appears
to be
an oversight and the team will look into
this
this is the kind of matter that the
examination process will tidy up
very easily through a minor modification
where
they'll just be able to add into their
outside of the meeting
i'll ask rob and the team to clarify the
number of dwellings that are
due to be proposed there so that
yourself and the parish council and any
concerned residents are able to make
their comments accordingly
um for what they perceive is is is due
there
and just to kind of add in on this
question i think it's it's an important
point which is that all of the
allocations the more significant
allocations
come with their own policy wording text
and the allocations within ls01 don't
come with their own specific
policy wording text but i'd just refer
counsellors to lp01
which is the first of the development
management policies the first of the
local policies
and that policy would provide an
overarching approach to all of the
proposals that are shown on on page 208
and within the maps
as lso1 sites i hope that's helpful
thank you thank you tom um
are you so that you're going you're
satisfied with that now councillor
jameson
yes sir thank you very much that's great
thank you uh council hinton did you
have a further question
councillor hinton did you have a oh you
you've taken your hand down now have you
beg your pardon sorry hit the wrong
button um it was really a point on
what councilor arthur was saying uh just
a few minutes ago
this meeting is to discuss the draft
joint local plan
final submission and to approve it for
submission for final consultation
um so really it's the only time that
councillors have had to really discuss
it in any detail
in a formal manner so to say that we
shouldn't be talking about this that and
the other is uh rather sort of
disingenuous
uh and have you got a question council
hinton
uh well i did say that we're going to
debate later
moving on to debate after this sorry
madam chairman but if i could just come
to a question then
and that is to say that on page 45 where
it
talks about the uh the neighborhood plan
areas and the number of
properties etcetera that have proposed
to be built in in
various areas uh the fact that the outs
the outstanding planning permissions uh
as of the 1st of
april 2018 is rather disingenuous when
it comes to saying what the current
position
of outstanding permissions is surely we
can put a more up-to-date figure in
there than the two-year-old one
it is more up-to-date than that i don't
know the exact
date rob have you got the exact date
that um existing permissions were marked
up to
i think in in the in this um response to
this question this is um
as of the 1st of april 2018 because
that's the base state of the plan
so what that table is is doing is
setting a
neighborhood plan requirement for each
neighbor plan area now if some of those
um
planning permissions have been built
then that's obviously
going towards meeting that requirement
yeah i thought that council hinton you
were talking about the allocations and
whether they were
up to date um accepting that some of
them have already been
given consent and some some of them have
started um on site
is is that what you were asking it's
it's partly that and partly because if
you look at east bergholt mayan parish
and i know we're getting parochial here
but i
do represent each burkhold it talks
about outstanding planning permissions
12 when we know that at the moment there
are 155
with planning permission and 75
coming up for outline permission to be
discussed on reserve matters
so that it makes a bit of a mockery of a
figure of 12
and makes a 241 which is the total homes
required
already met
okay it is quite parochial so you'll
have to forgive me i'm i'm actually
searching through a paper copy to find
his bergot now
um are you satisfied 45
sorry page 45
he said oh okay um i thought you were
talking about the
that i was going to ask you are you
satisfied that the sites
indicated for east bergo i was looking
for that page are you satisfied that
they are
they're they're properly marked
uh i would say yes that they are
properly marked i wouldn't say that i
agree with them but i would say that
they are properly marked
based on the permissions that have been
all the planning applications that have
been put in
today okay
and the number that you're looking at
for east bergholt
the identified permissions at that point
for that piece of work
was the first of april 2018
for those figures and you're saying that
12 at that moment in time you don't
think was right
or you're saying what a shame that
moment in time was so long ago
uh the latter because in actual fact
when you look at
every single page on this document it's
at the bottom it says joint local plan
pre-submission
november 2020. so to then be using
april yeah but you i think you have to
accept i mean i might
rob of course is a lot more of an expert
on the preparation of local plans than i
am
but i think you have to accept don't you
counsel hinton that for different
um elements of the plan and it's
evidence-based you have to
you have to put a mark down in terms of
time
and that's the point that you work from
otherwise you'll never get to a point of
publishing a plan because you're having
to update it all the time
thank you i think we'll move on now um i
have one final question
um i hope it's a question from
councillor parker
and then after we've had um councillor
parker's
question we'll move on to debate
councillor parker have you got a
question please i
i have madam chair and i'll i'll be um
brief about it as well
um thank you you're welcome councillor
arthi
question for you um i it's been pointed
out to me by
uh by a local clerk that we are inviting
representation
uh for this proposal and it's a proposal
that i support wholeheartedly um
um since i'm since i'm talking about it
but it's been pointed out to me that
we're asking for representation
um uh on this between the 12th of
november and the 24th of december
which is precisely the time the parish
councils uh won't be meeting and
indeed i'm cognizant of the fact that
there are still a number of parish
councils that haven't been able to meet
uh throughout this year
so could you give me an assurance that
this
um uh proposal will be
uh really well advertised uh so that
those out in our communities
um are fully aware of
their obligations and and um are able to
um to put their representations forward
thank you
yes it will be but more than that i
would say that if you're talking about
paris councils
there there should be very little
in this document that
comes as a complete surprise
because it's based on the work that
we've done
over a number of years a lot of
parish councils will have engaged in the
process in 2017 and again
in 2019 and
i with the exception maybe
of a a few sites and we spoke about the
sprout and one earlier on
um i i don't think that there is
anything in here
that will come or should come as a
complete surprise to any of the parishes
so yes it will be publicized
yes we will be engaging with paris
councils i said that in my introduction
and as far as the six week period is
concerned
um i i don't think that that should be a
problem
it tends to be that if we give people
six weeks
they respond in the last week of the six
if we give them 12 weeks they'll respond
in the last week of the 12.
if we gave them two years they'd
probably respond in the last week of the
two years
so i i don't think for anybody that's
interested in what this plan means to
their community what it means to the
future of their residents
i don't think that anybody should should
fail
to engage if they want to
thank you um so now
i'll open the floor to debate uh would
anyone like to open the debate
uh councillor busby we'd like to start
the debate please
yes thank you madam chairman um picking
up on councillor hardacre's
point this wasn't an isolated incident
where
the we've had an application which has
been turned down
uh but is still in the plan whereas the
one of the parishes have got a
neighborhood plan
with an alternative site in it the cons
i understand there's quite a few in mid
suffix as well the concern about this is
that there will be quite a lot of
representation that goes to the
inspector
and we could see quite a few changes to
the plan which is a shame
but this is the problem that you get
when a plan takes so long to prepare i
guess
it will never be perfect at any one
point in time but
it does seem a shame that we haven't
taken
perhaps more notice of what villages and
parishes want in their neighborhood
plans
rather than perhaps what developers or
what we think is the best site
from my point of view it should be a
plan that's delivered bottom up rather
than top down if it was delivered bottom
up you wouldn't have a lot of these
problems
one of the other points that disappoints
me is that when we talk about
employment in the plan we say
that we'll be focusing on town centres
for retail and employment
and we've long tried to promote our town
centers as
as much as we can yet if we look at the
allocations
we have about 4200
houses allocated for southwest ipswich
area that's going round from clayton
through to worsted 4200
yet in hadley and needham market
there's only about 700 so we're putting
six times the number of houses
which will support ipswich as opposed to
our own market town centers are we
trying to create
a greater ipswich area because that
appears to be what the plan
is destined to do
um there were lots of questions in there
i think i don't know if they would
debate
points and i didn't make a note of all
of them i don't think
but as far as ipswich
fringe is concerned i mean i i would
refer you
back again to our previous consultation
work in
2017 and and we asked the question
and the answer came back that we should
be looking at
urban extension we should be looking at
our market towns
if you remember there were options in
there for a new settlement to provide
the level of growth that we we had to
accommodate
um and that didn't um gather universal
support
so we we have talked about
the options um on page 44 there's a
table on page 44
um that that gives you the percentages
and
i think um that reads 21
of development would go towards
settlements
in the ipswich fringe 33 to market towns
and urban areas
28 uh to core villages
um and then we've got nine percent
hinterland villages and four percent
uh hamlets and i think i think those
figures leave five percent
um for windfall development spread
across
the hierarchy um so
i i hear the point you're making but i
don't think in any way
it makes our plan um inappropriate
the first question you asked i'm afraid
i should have written down what it was
but i didn't so can you can you just run
run past me again what the first part of
your point was
i just intervene here um this really is
uh um
now we're moving on to the debate rather
than more
question and answer period i think we
you've had your period
um of answering questions
um so i think now we're moving on to
debate um counsellors
right i agree that's why i didn't ask
this in the question thing
it was just a statement to say that that
the example that
councillor harday could use wasn't an
isolated incident
a number of parishes where developments
have been
turned down yet they now appear in the
plan
um whereas the the villages have got
alternative sites in their neighborhood
plans which don't appear in the plan
making their neighborhood plans
not acceptable so you will we're likely
to get a lot of
representation is my point and it could
mean that we have to make a lot of
changes to the
to the jlp which will be a shame thank
you for those observations councillor
busby
we'll now move on to councillor norman
uh thank you very much um i'm madam
chairman uh i'm not going to repeat too
much of what um
councillor hardacrum well councillor
busby have mentioned already because it
is
on that point i would just like to sort
of state my case just for the security
because i know that residents will be
watching this and i just want to assure
them
um of what i just want to say so i won't
be long and i don't need a response to
what i'm about to say
but um i'd just like to say obviously as
a district councillor i am going to
support the joint local plan because it
is in the best interest of the district
um however i would just like to voice
the concerns of um for the people in my
ward
um just because the controversy does
come from this um allocation
on the runway uh where the land has been
refused twice by the planning committee
and is currently under appeal um
obviously
as we all know and has been mentioned
previously um
this application is being the decision
of the planning committee is being
defended by baber
um but equally it has been put into the
joint local plan as it wasn't before
um so i do think that's odd and
obviously with and obviously uh
councillor i think i do thank you as
well for your explanation you have
you have answered a lot of the questions
that i was going to mention which is why
i didn't put this in the question part
um equally this site does have many
issues that have already been identified
such as the heritage issues and the
environmental issues
which is why it was refused in the first
place um
obviously what i will do now is continue
to work with officers as i have done
i've spoken to tom barker about this
so this is an ongoing discussion that
isn't really for today but i just wanted
to express
obviously there is concern about this
site and i will be bringing this up
as further as the joint local plan is a
live document as well
so not everything you know from the
discussions today i didn't want to bring
it up too much because i know it's not
really of the hour
but i just wanted to assure residents
that with this specific
site obviously we know that we're not
happy about it
in in our ward i'm not happy about it
and council had a crew has mentioned his
concerns as well so i'll be
i'll be making those a case um
to the officers about that but for now i
just wanted to
you know assure my residents that i'm
doing everything i can on that regard
but in terms of the joint local plan
for the best of the district i will be
supporting you today thank you very much
thank you councillor norman councillor
carpendale
thank you madam chair um i feel i've got
to say
something about this um because i've
expressed my reservations about
aspects of the plan on on various
occasions
on the other hand i do recognize the
need for a valid plan
one that's up to date and there are lots
of positives in this one
but my my principal concern i think it's
really been hinted at already by other
speakers
and that's really this area south west
of ipswich which
won't come to a surprise as a surprise
to people because i've mentioned this
several times before
we've got several sites in this area
for hundreds of homes all of which are
going to generate
journey to work traffic on roads that
are already congested
uh there's precious little employment uh
in these villages along the a-12
so so they're all going to be heading
off to ipswich colchester london
wherever
and the the a12 corridor may well be a
strategic route but
um you would even dismiss the nightmare
of cop dock
we've got these junctions on an official
all the way down to the
essex border and they're dangerously
substandard and inadequate
and councillor hinton mentioned
something that we were told many years
ago
and it just seems to disappeared into a
black hole at the moment
what is going to happen to these
junctions because the additional traffic
is going to put enormous pressure on
them and they really are very dangerous
i think when you when you consider the
um the planned development on the
ipswich friend as well
uh the overall traffic levels really
don't bear thinking about
um if we are stuck with with all these
houses
on this corridor then we really need to
see some kind of a plan
for how it's all going to work how is it
actually going to function
my own ward is particularly burdened
with the prospect of 70
growth but there's no vision for the
settlement as a whole
and i don't know if that applies to
other core villages that are going to
have a lot of development
we do seem to have an awful lot coming
coming our way
uh there's certainly no buy-in from the
village which means there's any
neighborhood plan is going to struggle
to get through its referendum
i mean obviously it's vital that we do
have a plan i do accept that
um i'm i'm very torn as to whether i can
actually support this plan and vote for
it
i recognize the need for it but um i
really do have
reservations and i i dare say that along
with my
um parish council and other residents
we'll we'll make some further um
representations during the next six
weeks
so i have yet to make up my mind if i
vote for it or
or if i don't thank you chairman thank
you councillor carpendale
councillor fraser
can you hear me now now we can hear you
thank you all right thank you sorry uh
just a yeah
a bit of a lag there thank you madam
chairman um
yes i think in reflection uh with what
has
been said by many councillors i welcome
the the joint local plan as a district
councillor
representing hadley south um
we are looking at several hundred houses
within this
local plan and i think the key concern
for residents in hadley
is uh infrastructure and primarily
our southern access and
really we need very much in hadley
uh a southern relief road to bypass
uh the b1070
and so i certainly it's important and
whilst i remain a council i'll be
working hard with
councillors at district level and at
county level to ensure
that this strategic
look forward on uh improving this access
goes ahead if we are to support the
building of
such a large number of houses thank you
thank you councillor fraser uh
councilman mccraw
thank you chair uh
i'm going to support this i suspect uh
and i have several reasons for this
first of all it replaces the existing
core strategy
and i think we've all seen the problems
that we've had with that
in terms of conflict and in terms of the
length of time
preparation and how we felt the
consultation exercises went there
um it has many flaws not least of which
one of it might be my own very
involvement
in the council at this level i suspect
without with core strategy
i might never have been here so that's
another charge to lay at its doorstep
uh consultation exercises here though
have been
as extensive as any have ever seen uh
that wasn't the case before there's been
a solid parish response as
as councillor ashley referred to in his
initial introduction
member involvement i was involved in a
previous stage and i'm really happy to
see the work of the
of the members working party um
throughout that
they should be thanked by the way for
that and in fact all officers should be
thanked because i know how
difficult this job has been as i've been
involved in discussions throughout
not everybody's going to get what they
want here
um we have to comply after all with the
nppf and i think many of us have
issues with the content of the nppf and
particularly nppf2
but this must be passed
to the inspector we must vote for this
in my opinion
we're going to have to look to benefit
from any transitional arrangements
that might apply before the government
impose a new calculation method which
would see
our housing targets more than double and
the council have made a good response to
that
and we must also be ready to deal with
what might emerge from the white paper
proposals
and we must get ready before those can
take effect
it's essential that we pass this joint
local plan so i shall be voting for it
thank you council mccraw now i'm aware
that councillor ward wants to
exercise his right to speak but does
anyone else want to come in on the
debate
before we move to uh closing this and
bringing in council award oh um
councillor osborne councillor adrian
osborne would you like to speak
yes thank you madam chairman uh yes i'd
like to um
express my opinions on on on the local
plan i think
we were wrong overdue for to have a a
good local plan as councillor arthur has
said
it's one of the best ones uh that i have
witnessed since i've been on council
and but the one the one trigger for it
all
and the it's been hit on the head many
times i think
councillor carpenter made that point and
i have the same one and that is about
the infrastructure
if we are going to make areas such as
our market down here in sudbury
uh good then they need to have good
infrastructure around it
we've already got a lot of housing uh
coming up
and around us and one of the one of the
main
uh uh concerns of our residence is the
amount of traffic that will once again
come into sudbury so i'm afraid
i you know i'm i just hope that we can
get
the the issues of infrastructure sorted
out with
uh uh suffolk county council or the
highways england
it is needed no doubt about it and it's
just not
our area i recognize the fact that it's
in a lot of other areas
so um i will support this because it is
a good
local plan and like and i very much uh
condone that the the work that have been
done by
by our officers and the um working joint
working group that came in with it and
and thanks again to clive arthur for
excellent presentation thank you
thank you councillor osborne um
councillor lindsay
thanks chair yeah um i guess there's
kind of leader of the green group i hope
to
well it's really my view i don't speak
for my group and they
uh as always we um
they vote on their own um conscience
um we don't we don't have a whip in our
group but
i i think it's worth saying that i
feel deeply conflicted by this and i um
i have i'm sort of teaching which way to
go
because i accept that we need it because
if we don't
have it um will have sort of
virtually no protection against
development and it's something that's
forced on us by the government but
i just feel this is a time when we
declared a climate emergency
um this plan is going to
significantly add to carbon emissions
even if the government
get around to to insisting on zero
carbon homes
this will be building houses it'll take
them some time
and and there'll be extra carbon as
several people have pointed out
many of these greenfield developments
will simply put more cars on the road
the idea that they're sustainable is
frankly laughable in
a lot of cases people will not be these
are not we're not building houses
that are car free we're building houses
that are car dependent
and that's going to be the single
biggest contributor um
to carbon emissions in this county all
these new homes
that we're building and furthermore
their private homes
are built for profit they do not meet
local need
there's not a need for all these homes
so for all those reasons i
i don't particularly like the local plan
but
um i accept that i may have to vote for
it
with um with gritted teeth thank you
thank you for your views councillor
lindsay council multi
thank you madam chairman um i'd like to
um challenge um councillor lindsay's
claim
that this local plan will increase
emissions
we've worked very hard to produce a
climate change action plan
and yesterday we passed the
biodiversity action plan and the two
combined will work very hard
at reducing the overall emissions um
the next thing obviously will be the um
design guide
and that too will reduce emissions so
i'm
very supportive of the joint local plan
we need it
we have to move forward we can't stand
still
and we certainly don't want to go back
thank you
thank you council malvizi would anyone
else like to speak before
i return to council award
so council award uh would you like to
exercise your right to speak please
thank you madam chairman i would and and
just quickly before i uh go into what i
was
intending to say uh i i do disagree with
councillor lindsay
these houses are needed try telling the
uh to young families looking for new
homes to live in to bring up their
families that
there's no need um and you you'll see
that uh that's not true
um councillors um hinton and carpenter
have talked about the a12 this is one of
two trunk roads
uh in in our district um there are huge
pressures on
on this road and we must keep up the the
pressure on highways england
who seem to be giving us mixed messages
i know the infrastructure delivery plan
that uh idp090
uh talks about junction 32 at capless
mary but there's nothing about junction
31 the four sisters
um and we've got to make sure that we
get something in it
to uh to recognize the pressures on that
particular junction
anyway just to um to go on to what i
wanted to say
i am very pleased to second the
recommendations in this paper
as you have heard it is the culmination
of several years of detailed work by our
dedicated planning policy team
and across party working group of
members of both councils
i thank all of them for that it is an
excellent document and will give us a
robust and detailed framework for future
development
in the district and now i know many of
us may have specific concerns about
individual sections
particularly the site allocations as you
have heard but it is a living document
and any issues can be addressed in
future revisions so that
individual reservations we may have can
be assuaged
it is perfectly possible to support the
plan because of the district level
benefits of having one
while still object to specific
allocations the important thing is that
it is our plan
it belongs to all 32 of us indeed it
belongs to all 66 members of both
councils
it has been agreed by our
representatives on the working group and
includes ideas and desires from all
political groups
it is essential that we proceed and
submit this local plan for inspection
we need it not just because as
councilman crore has alluded
our existing plan is becoming out of
date with policies that are often
challenged
and because it is based on obsolete
housing targets
but also because the planning landscape
is likely to change drastically in the
near future
following publication of the white paper
and the proposed changes to the current
planning system
we therefore need a local plan that is
defensible during this period of change
there is no reason for any of us not to
support this local plan
the broad principles and the policies
are sound and are what we have said we
want
the alternative would be having no plan
and the consequences that would have
inappropriate development our
communities would not thank any of us
for that
i shall be voting to approve the joint
local plan regulation 19 document this
evening
and i look forward to following its
progress through the examination process
thank you madam chairman
thank you councillor ward councillor rc
uh would you like to sum up and uh make
any comments
i i will it'll be um very quick
i've i've heard what everybody has said
in the debate
and i i would simply say um we
can't be without a fully compliant
up-to-date plan um we
we won't have a fully adopted plan until
later on next year but we will now have
a document that carries
some weight so it is a material planning
consideration
in the determination of applications
i've heard what people have said about
the examination next year
and i'm sure there will be some
changes as a result of that
i don't believe there will be very many
significant changes to
our plan because i believe it's a very
good plan
i think that i've heard what people have
said about infrastructure
obviously we've got an infrastructure
paper about seal coming up
next um and i would only say
that um we've we've had seal um
since i've been charging sales since
2016.
um when it comes to the provision of
infrastructure
never mind um the the other
infrastructure providers remember that
we will be a
key player in funding infrastructure
requirements
we've collected a significant amount of
money through community infrastructure
levy
and we we will be part of the provision
of the infrastructure that communities
need moving forward we won't be
providing all of it of course but we
will be a big player
in the provision of the infrastructure
that most of you have identified in your
communities
as as being deficient so we we can be a
part of that
chairman lastly i just wanted to to
confirm the recommendations
they're in the paper um did you want me
to read them or did you want to read
them
don't worry i'll read those in a moment
so if you cut
if you finish your summing up i'll um
read the recommendations thank you
i have thank you chairman i urge members
to support the submission of the plan
for examination next year
thank you councillor arthi so yes
for clarity and to enable viewers
um watching this meeting on youtube
um and anyone who may not have had the
opportunity to see the recommendations
i will now read the recommendations that
we are about to vote on
so the recommendations are 3.1
that the baba admits suffolk joint local
plan
pre-submission regulation 19
document november 2020 appendix a
be approved for publication under
regulation 19
of the town and planning act local
planning england
regulations 2012 as amended
point to 3.2
that delegated authority is given to the
assistant director
for sustainable communities in
consultation with a cabinet member for
planning
to submit the joint local plan
pre-submission
regulation 19 document to the secretary
of state
for an independent examination
and for modification and procedural
processes
necessary for the examination
3.3 that the addendum to the statement
of community involvement
november 2020 appendix e
be approved so those are the
recommendations
the corporate manager governance and
civic office
will now take a roll call vote on the
proposal
thank you chair members please can you
respond with four
against or abstain counsellor arthy
four councillor is four
councillor barrett four councillor beer
four councillor busby four
councillor carpendale reluctantly
four councillor creswell
four councillor davis oh
councillor fraser four councillor gold
four councillor grandin four
councillor hardacre reluctant four
councillor hinton reluctant against
councillor jameson four councillor
lindsay
four councillor malfeasy four
councillor mccraw
councillor mccraw
i'll come back to council mccraw
councillor mclaren four
councillor newman four councillor norman
four councillor none four
councillor adrian osborne or
councillor jan osborne four
councillor owen or councillor parker
four councillor plum four council award
four councillor mccrory are you with us
i am indeed my apologies i was
temporarily ejected
four okay thank you
chair that is carried
the vote was carried thank you
so we'll now move on to item four on our
agenda today
bc 29
community infrastructure levy sil
provo proposed revised civil charging
rates
for consultation purposes for baba
district council
and mid suffolk district council are
still charging authorities for their
administrative areas
i would like to invite councillor arthy
to introduce paper bc
29 and to move the recommendations in
the report
counselor arthi
thank you chairman okay
having lost my screen for my previous
introduction
um i i've taken the precaution of
printing off what i'm going to say so
that you won't have
um or i won't have the embarrassment of
having nothing to
to present um thank you chairman baber
is a seal charging authority this was
formally agreed in january 2016
when the sale charging scheme was
adopted the sealed charging rates
were agreed following viability testing
and
charging started on the 11th of april
2016.
it was made clear at the time that rates
were likely to remain for at least three
years
given the current position reached with
our joint local plan
it is considered appropriate to formally
review the sill charging rates for both
baba and mid-suffolk
you will also be aware of the
infrastructure funding statement
that was considered by cabinet yesterday
the existing sill rates are at appendix
i
but they are subject to index indexation
so the latest indexed rates shown at
paragraph 4.5
represent our current charges
the original installments policy is at
appendix c
following an assessment of whole plan
viability and
potential seal rates based on
infrastructure
needs planning policy requirements and
housing development market conditions
our viability consultant has recommended
changes
to the existing seal rates
the revised rates represent an increase
for greenfield residential development
but the evidence provided by our
viability consultant
is that they are reasonable the new
rates distinguish between greenfield and
brownfield sites
and sites where there is an affordable
housing requirement
but are a flat rate in place of the
existing
high and low charging zones
the viability consultants also concluded
there is no longer a requirement to
consider any sites as having strategic
status
this simplifies the schedule further so
that all
undeveloped sites without planning
commissions
will be still chargeable
the seal member panel has had several
meetings to formulate the proposals for
the revised sell charging rates in
appendix a
and we're also keen to compare our rates
with those of other sill charging
authorities
these are included at appendix m
whilst our rates must rely on viability
evidence
we were reassured to find the proposed
rates
were comparable with other charging
authorities
proposed revisions to the installment
policy are an appendix
n it seems reasonable to review the
installment policy at the same time
as the rates review the member panel
supported a simplified installment
policy
which considered the needs of the house
builders particularly the smaller ones
and the parishes who need to plan for
sell receipts
to support community infrastructure
delivery
your approval is sought for a six-week
consultation on the proposed revisions
to run from the 12th of november to the
24th of december
the same period has agreed for
representations on the local plan
details and consultees are set out at
paragraph
9.1 of bc29
chairman i'm proposing the
recommendations in paragraphs 3.1 and
3.2
of our report which are for these
proposals to be subject to a six-week
consultation
with the responses being considered by
our viability consultants
and fed back into the examination in
public
we will then consider the expect the
inspectors report
before adoption on a date to be agreed
the recommendations are worded for both
baber and mid suffolk
but my proposal relates just to us
so please replace the both council's bit
at the start of its recommendation
with baba district council on behalf
of the member group i would like to
thank christine thurlow
and her team for all their hard work and
the detailed analysis to bring this to
you today
christine is with us this evening as is
stuart cook
from our viability consultants to answer
any detailed questions you may have
i'm proposing 3.1 and 3.2
of bc 29 as amended
and ask for a seconder thank you
chairman
thank you councillor arthy could i have
a second dad please
i'd be happy to second this as well uh
madam chairman council award here
thank you council award so we'll now
move on to
questions and debate counsellors are
asked to comment on the proposed
response
and if there are any amendments to this
response
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish however
but they must be relevant to the subject
excuse me under discussion i must be a
question
when we move to debate counselors will
only be asked to speak
once be able to speak once for three
minutes
and this will be timed so we'll move on
to questions
now do you have any questions please
regarding this paper
would anyone like to start the questions
counselor hinton would like to open the
questions please
just a quick question please madam
chairman there's more of a
point of clarification as much as
anything else um
am i correct in in thinking that uh
having read these these papers as well
that
we're now going away from a a two-tier
sill
structure to a single tier structure so
that
the villages like mine don't get
penalized uh over the towns in terms of
how much still they pay
yes the new proposals don't have zoning
any longer
thank you uh that was a nice simple
answer
um councilman crawl you have a question
i think for brevity i'd just like to
councillorati if he could confirm
that this in fact is the only decision
we are making here today
is to send this document out for
consultation the consultees will have
their chances to
uh to put their input into that and
then it will be brought back to council
for a final decision
so that's the only decision we're making
to send the document out for
consultation
and if that's the case um
is that correct could we clarify
councillor arthi please
yes yes that is correct um and um
just to add that the proposals are
coming from
um the the member group um who've worked
on
um all of the sil revisions and are
working on
the the framework review which will be
um coming soon
so yes it's it's the suggested
review suggested revisions um and they
will go out to consultation
thank you councillor okay thank you
are there any more questions before we
move on to debate
so there do not appear to be any further
questions so
um now i invite you to start to start
the debate
please
councillor busby would you like to open
the debate
thank you yes i'm surprised clive didn't
start by saying that he was following
scientific evidence
that we've studied what we
need to spend and have therefore
increased our income accordingly
which is fine except we're doubling the
rates
almost and that's a concern to me when
we've got house prices that are already
in excess of what most people can afford
to add another 10 20 000 pounds onto the
cost of each house
seems a little short-sighted i know mr
arthy
will likely to say that it should drive
down land prices
and i hope it does but much of the land
has already been
bought for housing to go up in the
future
in the near future at least
so i'm really concerned that we're not
just inflating
house prices by uh doubling our seal
rates
councillor hinton um would you like to
join the debate
[Music]
ah it's playing up gotcha um yes i
i agree with what uh councillor busby
said but i would also say that
there is one um well two
good points within this uh document and
and they are one the taking away of the
zoning
because it was um penalizing the
villages and making them effectively
more
unaffordable than uh they were before
uh but the other the good thing is
another good thing
is the fact that we're now tiering the
rates
the payment of the sill a bit more
because i've had developers say to me
that one of the crippling things about
and that's holding them back from new
developments is the fact that they have
to pay the sill
all of it up front um before they've
even started and the
smaller developers that do not have
access to the funding from banks that
everybody else seems to
to get taken for granted probably
because they don't want to borrow quite
so much as the big developers do
so there are benefits to this scheme and
i hope that
they will be highlighted when it goes
out for consultation and that the
public will have a chance to comment on
them
thank you councillor hinton councillor
carpendale
thank you madam chair um can i first
thank the uh the working group for for
the uh the time they put in on this and
and also to christine thurlow and her
team
um you know they've done a lot of work
and uh
christine's also given me the benefit of
her explanation and rationale
um for the proposed increases that we're
looking at
um i can see that our still charges are
are comparable in fact they're quite low
or they have been
but i'm a little bit on the same track
as uh councillor busby because
um i do wonder about the impact on house
prices compared to
uh the earnings that we have in baber
we're already at 11 to one
as a ratio which is pretty high um
and that does just worry me a bit
because it it um it then puts us into
all sorts of dangerous positions with
regard to
to build out and and meeting our targets
for build and so on
um having said that i i can see that
clearly if we're going to need all this
infrastructure we're going to need
need the money from somewhere so um i
should certainly support this but i do
have concerns about the impact on our
house price and earnings ratio
thank you councillor of copendale
council mclaren
uh thank you madam chairman uh i'm a
member of the sil review panel
and a lot of work has gone into
the conclusions that we've got before us
today but i want to pay
tribute to clive and david byrne
for their supervision if you like and
wealth of knowledge
but most of all to christine thurlow and
her team
they have done a magnificent job and
they work very hard
and well done to them thank you
thank you council mclaren councillor
ward
yes um just just a comment on the uh
potential impact on on house prices and
i i think um house prices
are more controlled by the um supply and
demand
um issue than than the potential for
uh seal to inflate prices at least
that's what the
standard method for calculating our
housing number
is is predicated on um and i'm sure
that's the case
um if we build houses uh more houses
then
um the price will be uh will not so much
come down but will be paid um
at a level that people can afford
hopefully
um uh i'm i'm more um
uh i suppose uh encouraged by
the paragraph 1.9 in in this particular
report here which um says that the uh
these new proposed rates have gone
through significant viability testing
and uh that demonstrates uh that um
the rates of still these new races so
would not render any development sites
as undeliverable
so i'm i'm satisfied that um and also as
um councillor carpendale i think has has
mentioned our rates are quite um
favorable compared with others
i'm i'm more than happy to uh to be
satisfied that these these
new proposed rates are going to be um
achievable and will not have a
detrimental impact on on development in
the district
thank you thank you council ward i will
just mention that
um that is your only opportunity to
speak on this
yes that's all i wanted to say fine
thank you
count councillor busby
sorry just very quickly just to say that
um
we are supposed to build houses for
locals um
you might be building houses for
londoners that's my only concern
councilman mccraw
thank you chair um i'm not too sure
about
bringing regionality into it councillor
busby because uh
in all honesty i mean there was a time
when i didn't live in this area and i
have many friends
who've moved to this area from that very
place you talk of
i think at the time we've been talking
so much about the requirements of
infrastructure
that actually looking as we plan to look
at
are principal vehicle for providing
local infrastructure
uh is exactly what we should be doing
and
if there are any reservations any
problems well
i'm sure they're going to emerge during
the consultation process
everybody will have their chance to make
their point and then
at that point the council will then be
able to take that evidence
the working party will be able to put
something together and bring this back
to council
i believe in all honesty we should just
vote for this straight away
i think we may be about to do that um
but before we do that
uh is there anyone else who would like
to
make a point in this debate
oh councillor fraser
um thank you madam chairman um yes uh
i'm being a londoner
and um moving to here to suffolk um
yeah i was quite surprised that uh
councillor busby's
remark just there and i think he should
withdraw it thank you
do you not agree that we should be
building houses for locals
we should be building houses for
everyone we're not here
so i think um we'll now uh refrain from
uh
that kind of debate um
so cancer arthy would you like to sum up
um again my summing up would be very
brief
i just wondered though um that there
have been a few comments
um about viability
comments about how some house builders
will have already bought sites and
they're going to be surprised by the
increase in the rates
this work was underpinned by a viability
assessment and we've got with us
the consultant who did that i mean
would it be okay for stuart cook just
just to address that point on
sustainability
sorry viability not sustainability
we've lost you chairman
sorry i had a few technical issues
together
i had some of those earlier on i lost my
papers
i think i think they're resolved okay
the the question was before we
before i sum up um would it be okay just
to ask
our viability consultant stuart cook
just to address that issue of
viability that a few members spoke about
yes please do
thank you that's if he's still with us
stuart
yeah i'm still here um yeah
this is set up in terms of our viability
assessment
it has had regard to best practice set
up
in practice guidance um and
in the ppg it's clear that all
development costs do have to come off of
land value um so and and
and and that's a very clear method and
so developers
um should be aware not to be over
bidding for sites or using that that as
a
as an excuse not to be paying for policy
and
this enhanced um soil charge which is uh
proposed
in terms of that's your viability
assessment itself what when we're
looking to set a new rate
um the actual um assessment
um considered current um
sales values so the best but
based upon current prices achieved in
the market so
um it's not
sort of um looking forward and try to
inflate values to accommodate
a new new soil charge and furthermore
um when we set the sale charges provide
sell
charges itself we've allowed for what
they call viability buffer
to absorb any change changes in the
market and
based upon our testing we we think that
the values could probably
the proposed cell rates uh could absorb
sort of between maybe five or ten
percent four within values as well so
the the there's a number of buffers
built into that size as well
to understand changing in the market so
so so we're not pushing
the rates at the margins of viability
that that they're very much affordable
and represent enhanced rate as well
okay thanks thanks for that stuart so
the only thing that i would
add to that before i sum up really is um
that if there's anything um that we do
know about
um the development and house building
industry it's that they do like
certainty
um the previous regime before seal
with 106 um contributions um there
there was no certainty there was
certainty there was going to be
something but there wasn't certainty
about how much it would be
because that had to be negotiated after
the grant that of course is later on in
the process
um the the cell charging regime is known
up front
so that's why it should impact on on
land values
so um chairman i think on the last item
you wished to read out the um
recommendations that um yes yep
okay thank you very much now again i'd
urge members to
to support um the proposals and they are
as councillor mccraw said they are for
a period of consultation and um and
reassessment
thank you councillor arthur so yes as
before
i'll read out the recommendations for
clarity
and to enable those who do not have the
words in front of them to
be aware of them so the recommendations
are as
follows and this is what we will be
voting on
3.1 that baba district council approved
the content of this report
and all appendices with a view to
agreeing
that this material will be the subject
of a formal consultation
for a period of six weeks between the 12
november
and 24th december 2020
this would be a separate consultation
but run in parallel with the
consultation exercise
for the emerging joint legal plan
3.2 that baba district council agree
that all responses to the consultation
result relating to revisions to the
rates of still clarking
will be considered analyzed by the
council's liability consultants
and taken into account and fed into an
examination
in public to be held by an inspector
weber district council also agreed to
fully consider the inspector's report
when the examination in public is
concluded
together with any consequent inspector's
report
issued with his or her findings to both
councils this would allow both councils
to consider
outcomes together with any revision and
subsequent adoption
of any new revised cell charging rates
for both councils together with an
implementation date
now i'm aware that quite a few councils
have had to leave the meeting
to go to other parish and town council
meetings
but we will now have a vote so i invite
the
corporate manager governance and civic
office to take a roll call vote
on the proposal thank you
thank you chair members please can you
respond with four against or abstain
cancer arthy four councillor barrett
four councillor beer four
councillor busby four councillor
carpendale
four councillor davis four
councillor fraser councillor gould
four councillor grandin four
councillor hardacre four councillor
melveezy
four councilmember mccrore four
councillor mclaren
four councillor newman
four councillor norman four
councillor none four councillor adrian
osborne
four councillor jan osborne four
councillor parker four
council awards four
chair that is carried unanimously thank
you
that vote was carried unanimously so
thank you very much for everyone's hard
work
um on the papers tonight and for the
presentation
um that vote is carried and um thank you
all for attending this evening
our next meeting is on the 24th of
november
at 5 30 but um
now i think we can call this evening's
meeting closed
thank you very much at 7 42 our
meeting this evening is closed thank you
all very much for attending
you